RYAN BOYD: Hi, everyone.
Welcome back for those of you
who were in the first session
here today.
I'm happy to introduce
here Dan Holevoet.
Dan Holevoet is the lead on our
developer relations team
for App Engine, and he's going
to be here today talking about
using Google Cloud Endpoints to
connect your mobile apps to
the cloud without breaking
a sweat.
For those you weren't here in
the first session, Cloud
Endpoints is our technology
that allows you to take
advantage of Google's underlying
API serving
infrastructure that we use for
building many of our own APIs.
And so Dan is going to talk to
you about how you can use that
to build your APIs.
Dan.
DAN HOLEVOET: Thanks, Ryan.
A little too many spoilers
in that there.
People aren't going to have
any excitement here.
Yes.
So I'm Dan, and I'm here today
to talk to you about Cloud
Endpoints as Ryan said, which
is a really cool way to
connect your mobile backends
to clients running in
JavaScript, Android,
or iOS devices.
So to start off before I get
too far into the slides, if
anyone wants to follow along
at home, I've got a QR code
here you can use to grab the
slide link or short line at
the top if you want to type
that into your laptops.
I'll give you a second
to grab that.
I see a few devices still
up in the air.
Three, two, one.
OK.
All right.
Perfect.
So to start off, I'm going to
do a very brief overview of
App Engine.
I don't know.
How many of you were in
the previous talk.
OK.
Most of you.
So I'll go through this
really quick.
So App Engine is a really great
way for you to build
applications running on Google's
infrastructure that
makes it easy to build, easy to
scale, and easy to maintain
your applications running
in the cloud.
So when I say easy to build,
you can write your
applications in three languages,
three runtime that
we have available, so that's
Java, Python, and Go.
And in addition to that, we have
a bunch of services that
make it easier for you to build
out these applications,
so things like NoSQL datastore,
Cloud SQL,
Memcache, different types of
environments that you can use
to run your code, so like front
ends and backends, task
queues for dividing up work
into small little tasks.
And then you can run them in the
background, cron jobs for
running things periodically, and
then a set of other APIs
and services that you can
use that make your
applications richer.
So user's API that allows you
to have users log in with
Google accounts, mail API for
sending email, and image API
for manipulating images, URL
Fetch to basically interact
with all the other web services
running on the
internet, MAP producing, traffic
splitting, search, the
list goes on and on.
I'm not going to talk about all
those today, but you can
see a full list if you go
to developers.googl
e.com/appengine.
App Engine also makes it
really easy to build
applications at scale.
This is an actual traffic graph
from an application that
was experiencing a very
traffic-heavy event.
I believe it was a concert on
their website, live streamed.
So these peaks here, were
basically going from zero
requests per second here on this
long bar on the left all
the way up to a peak of 19,000
requests per second and then
here a peak of 23,000
requests per second.
So this is all happening about
over a period about an hour so
you can see here these are
really significant spikes, and
there's very deep troughs after
each of these fights
because App Engine is very
quick to respond to high
demand, and it's also a very
quick to scale back down once
you no longer need
the resources.
So you're not paying for
resources that you don't need
because App Engine is scaling
up and down very quickly to
respond to traffic.
And then finally, I mentioned
App Engine is
very easy to maintain.
And I have a quote here from
one of our partners over at
Rovio who's building web
applications on App Engine.
And the important thing to
remember about App Engine is
when you're deploying
applications onto App Engine,
you're not worrying if the
server is going to stay up.
Google has an entire team of
site reliability engineers
making sure that applications
running in our data centers
are staying alive.
So this is something you don't
have to really think about
once you deploy on our cloud.
This is probably a slide that's
very familiar to you if
you saw Ryan's presentation.
This is a typical month in
the life of App Engine.
We have a million active
applications running every
month, more than two trillion
datastore operations, and then
my favorite statistic, half of
all the active IP addresses in
the world touch an App Engine
service actually every week,
not every month.
So these are things like
user-facing applications also
servers talking to each other,
exchanging data, doing data
processing, mobile applications,
connecting to a
backend like I'll be talking
about today.
So the real meat and potatoes,
why we're here today, building
mobile backends with
App Engine.
So this is probably a story
that many of you
are familiar with.
How many of you have
mobile apps?
OK.
That's a good guess.
How many of you have backends
for those mobile applications,
they don't just run a device?
OK.
Not as quite as many as I
expected, but a lot of you.
So you start out.
You buy a server.
You put it somewhere.
Maybe you're running a server
from someone that are
co-located.
You build a stack basically
picking what software it is
you want to run.
Maybe it's Apache.
Maybe it's No JS.
Whatever it is, you
install that.
You figure out what services
you need to support your
application, things like
chat, or mail, or
maybe a search API.
Then you think, OK, well, how am
I going to connect this to
my mobile device?
I'll probably write an API.
Well, do I need authorization?
Do I need authentication?
What wire format should I use?
Writes are important when I'm
sending them over the wire.
These are mobile devices.
I probably need compression.
And then you think, OK, well,
I've got all these different
platforms I'm targeting.
I probably want to build a
wrapper for all of these
clients, right?
So maybe I want a JavaScript
client.
Maybe I want a Java client.
Maybe I want Objective
C client.
Just target the major platforms
where I'm building
these applications.
And then you launch your
application, and you realize
you need to start over because
the decisions that you made at
the beginning of the process
turned out they didn't scale
quite the way that you
wanted them to.
And at this point, you realize
what you're actually spending
your time on is not building
your application.
It's worrying about all this
other stuff that wasn't the
reason you started out
building mobile apps.
You're not thinking about
cool features that you
can add to your game.
You're not thinking about
how you can monetize.
You're not thinking how
you get more users.
You're thinking about oh, my
server is going to crash,
because I can only handle
10 more QPS before
it explodes, right?
And that's not a cool story.
It's not a cool place to be.
So this is a happy talk.
And I'm going to talk to you
about how Endpoints solves a
lot of these problems.
So Endpoints allows you to
extend your App Engine
backends by easily adding APIs
that you can consume from
within mobile devices,
so that's JavaScript,
Android, and iOS.
And Endpoints has a lot of
different features that I'll
talk about.
So to start off, you
can build your
backends in Java and Python.
There's no ghost support at
the moment, but we're, of
course, looking into that
because it's one of the
languages supported
on App Engine.
And all this is built on
Google's API infrastructure.
So when you build APIs with
Endpoints running on App
Engine, those APIs are being
hosted on the same API
infrastructure that powers
Google's other APIs.
So if you've ever used things
like the G+ API, or the
calendar API, or the Tasks API,
all of those things run
on the same infrastructure
that powers Endpoints.
And there are some really cool
things that you can get
because of that shared
infrastructure, and I'll talk
a little bit more about
these later.
But if you've ever used like the
API's Explorer as a way to
try out new APIs or experiment
with APIs, you get that for
free by using Endpoints
because it's the same
infrastructure.
All of these APIs are our using
JSON and they get free
GZip compression over the wire,
so you're sending nice,
efficient packets to your
mobile applications.
We provide three client
libraries for
all of these APIs.
So if you're building Java or
Objective C applications, you
get a nice, statically-typed
client library automatically
generated for you.
And the helper code that we're
writing works with the same
library that you would use if
you were using those same
other Google APIs.
So if you're writing an app that
uses the Google+ API and
whatever API it is that
you've built, you
have one client library.
So you're not worrying about
bloating all of your
applications because you've
got one client library for
this feature and another client
library for this feature.
It's the same client library.
And then we also have a
JavaScript client library that
you can use, of course, in
the web browser, and I'll
demonstrate all of these
in a couple minutes.
OAuth 2 is built right into the
product, so if you want to
do authentication, it's really
straightforward to set that up.
You can log into your
applications using Google
Account, and I'll actually talk
a little bit more about
this later as well.
And then we have some
great tooling
support as part of Endpoints.
So if any of you have used the
Google plug-in for Eclipse,
we've extended that with the App
Engine features and also
Endpoints features to make
it really easy to develop
Endpoints APIs within the
development environment that
you're familiar with.
And of course, because this is
part of the App Engine SDK,
you get the same local
development experience that
you get with the rest of the
product, and you'll see that
in a moment as well.
So Endpoints, how
does it work?
So you basically start out
writing backend code.
All of my slides today are going
to be demonstrating the
backends in Java, but rest
assured all this works and
Python as well.
And I've got lots of sample code
at the end of the slide
deck that you can check
out later on.
So we've got a very simple class
here that represents a
game and we're taking
in a board object.
We're going to update that
and send it back.
Very straightforward code.
So let's turn this
into an API.
So the first thing we have
to do is, we add this API
annotation here.
And then we can basically
stop.
This is all we actually have to
do in order to get an API.
Everything else is done by our
SDK and the tooling that we
provided, and you can get
an API from this.
So this will turn it into
something like game Endpoint.
By default, it will have one
method update game that takes
one of these board objects.
And there's certainly ways you
can customize this, which I'll
talk about as I do
some live coding.
But this is the bare
minimum you need in
order to get an API.
So it's very simple
to start with.
So once you have this, we've
got some tooling
that I talked about.
This is basically a command that
you'd run on the command
line that gives you your
Objective C client library.
Generates a bunch of
files for you.
Drop those into Xcode, and then
you can start consuming
them with some lines
like this.
So it's just a couple lines
of code in order to make a
request to your API that's
running on App Engine.
So maybe I've convinced some of
you that it's pretty neat,
but I'm sure that there are
folks out there who'd really
like to see a demo.
So let's switch over
into Eclipse.
All right.
So I have this really simple
application, tic-tac-toe, that
I have running on my
local machine here.
Actually, all start out with
a demo of this app.
So like I said very, very
simple application.
This is definitely going
to make millions
and millions of dollars.
So you can see here I've got
this really simple board, and
if I click on any of these
buttons, each time I hit one
of these buttons, this is taking
the current state of
the board, sending it off
to my app Engine server.
The computer is filling in a
move, sending it back to me,
and then when I win, because
the computer is not very
smart, it's recording my score
for all posterity and then
refreshing this list
at the bottom.
So let's see how we'd build
something like that.
So we start out with the
App Engine backend.
So this is the code that
I've written here.
So I have two types of
primitive objects.
The first one is a board object,
very, very simple, and
the second one that I'm looking
at here is the score
object, which basically keeps
track of all the games that I
previously played.
So if you're familiar with App
Engine, you might recognize
this actually or other
Java environments.
You might recognize this as a
JDO class, so nothing changes
about this.
This is the same type of JDO
object that you would write in
other environments or with
another part of App Engine
that don't use Endpoints.
So there's no changes
to this code it all.
It just exists as
it did before.
And then we have an Endpoint
class that basically reads and
writes these objects and sends
them over the wire.
So the first thing we want to
do if we want to make this
class an endpoint, is we will
add this API annotation as I
said before to make
sure we import the
right packages here.
And so what we're going to do
is we could just stop with
this, and we would
have an API.
But we'd like to customize
it a little bit.
So what we're going to do first
is we're given a name.
I can also do things
like specify what
version I want to run.
If you want to have multiple
versions of an API going at
the same time, that's
totally fine.
You can totally do that.
By default, this will give me
V1 of the API, which seems
perfectly fine for
demo purposes.
And then by adding this
annotation, all of these other
methods are automatically going
to be added to the API
that I built.
So I'll have a getMethod and
I'll have a listMethod that
returns all the previous
scores that
I've saved in my datastore.
But we also have this other
endpoint or this other API as
part of the same tic-tac-toe
API.
This is a board endpoint that
allows me to interact with the
current state of the board.
So rather than having all of
these things sort of munged
into one name space, I'm going
to give these custom names.
So my API method now
will be scores.get
rather than just GET.
And you'll see the importance of
that a little bit later as
I actually demonstrate how
to consume these APIs.
So make sure we're importing
the right package there.
And then we'll do the same
process for these other
methods, so we've scores.list
and then scores.insert.
And while I'm messing around
with this code, one quick note
on how to do the authentication
piece here.
So for the backend, this is
actually very simple.
If I wanted to figure out who
the current user was making
one of these requests, I just
add the user parameter into my
method signature.
There's one other thing that I
would need to do at the top
here in this annotation, but
this is basically it.
So I have this user object,
which represents the Google
account that is making
the API request.
And if you're familiar with App
Engine, this is the same
user object calling
google.appengine.api.users
that you would see
in other places.
So if you're doing App Engine
sign in and other parts of
your application, then you want
to compare those user
objects to the ones you're
getting from Endpoints,
they're exactly the same.
It's very, very simple to OAuth
support into these APIs,
which is not something that you
can usually say when it
comes to OAuth.
So we'll leave this
out for now.
We'll talk about that a
little bit more later.
So at this point, I basically
have my API already running.
So what we'll do is we'll deploy
this to App Engine.
Take a quick sip of my drink.
All right.
Now my API is serving.
Excellent.
So let's take a look at it.
So I had this URL here running
on local host.
We can actually switch over
to the one that's
running on LIVE server.
And the first thing that we're
going to look at is a
discovery document, and this is
basically, a description of
the API that I just wrote.
And this isn't necessarily
intended for human
consumption.
It's mostly intended for
other parts of the API
infrastructure to give us
things like the API's
Explorer, which I'll show you in
a minute or for generating
client libraries.
So this discovery document
describes the state of my API.
So it's the types of things
like, what objects am I my
accepting and returning.
What are the methods on my
API that I can call,
and things like that.
So if I have a URL parameter,
it shows up in here.
If I have things that show up
in the body, like I want to
insert a new score, that
shows up in the body.
That you can see in here.
And so with things like this,
I can then go into the API's
Explorer and actually I can
do this quick link.
And this will load, basically
allow me to explore all the
APIs that I've deployed on to
my App Engine application so
if I were to strip this off,
this would show me all of
Google's APIs and we provide
this nice little shortcuts so
that you can just filter down
to the APIs that you've
deployed on your application.
And so we've got the tic-tac-toe
API here.
And so we can try things like
get the current move or get a
computer's move given our
current state of the board.
So the way that we represent
the board in this game is a
one-dimensional array of
dashes, X's and O's.
So this is basically playing an
X in the center square, so
we'll send this off
to the computer.
And we can see here this is
basically what our requests
looks like, typical
format that you
would be familiar with.
So we're sending JSON from
the API's Explorer.
This is what the body looks
like, and then we're getting
back this response which looks
like a move of a zero in the
top right corner.
So the computer is
not very smart.
It will just play randomly.
If I keep running this,
it will keep
generating new results.
But that basically gives you an
idea of what the API call
convention looks like and what
the responses would look like.
So we could also try some of the
other things too so I can
get a list of all the
previously-played games.
And this will return this very
simple format, what the
outcome was, when it was played,
things like that of
all the previous games
that people played.
Tic-tac-toe.
And from this, it's actually
really simple to go into a
very simple JavaScript client.
So I have this application
running
here live on our server.
This is a very simple UI very
much like the Android one.
Every time I make one of these
moves, it's sending a request
off to my backend and
updating the game.
And so if you actually were to
look at these JavaScript
console, which hopefully you
guys can see here on the
screen, I can play again.
And you can see these requests
going off to my
backend as I play.
And my favorite thing is that
you can make calls to the
client library right from
within the console, and
because Chrome has auto
complete, you can actually
experiment with the APIs
pretty easily.
So you've got GAPI Client, which
is the code that you
always see in a client
library.
And then we're interesting cal
the tic-tac-toe API and we
have the board method, and we
have the scores method.
So let's call board.
And we can call getMove.
And we'll pass in state and
this is JavaScript, so of
course, we need to callback.
And we will log it.
All right.
So this is basically
the result--
maybe I have a typo in my--
Yes.
There we go.
All right.
So we have this object that we
get back, and inside of the
result is the currently-updated
state of the board.
So we can then consume that
within our application.
Pretty simple.
All right.
So this sort of demonstrates
the Java backend and the
JavaScript client case, but
you're probably also
interested in building native
mobile applications as well.
So let's jump back into Eclipse,
and we can see how
you might consume one
of these clients
or APIs within Android.
So the first thing that I would
do within my Eclipse
project is I would actually go
to the Google menu here, and I
would generate client or Cloud
Endpoint client library.
And so what this will do is, it
will send off a request to
generate client libraries for
the API that I've just
constructed.
This will make a whole bunch
of network requests and
basically download a zip file
for you, which you can copy
into your project.
Rather than demoing that, I
actually have an application
already configured with the
appropriate files, which you
see here on the left.
And I have this activity class,
which I can use to
interact with the API.
So I've already done all the
work for generating that
really simple UI the
you saw previously.
So the thing that we're going
to add to this is the logic
that allows us to make requests
over the network.
So we have three important
things to call.
So we have getTheComputerMove,
which happens every time I hit
one of the squares and that
spawns an asynchronous task.
We don't want to block
the UI thread.
So the first thing that we're
going to do here is we're
going to get a new board object
by calling service,
which is basically an object
that we used to call our APIs.
We're going to call board just
like we did in the JavaScript
case because that's
the resource that
we're interested in.
And we're going to call getMove,
which is the method
that we want to call.
And we're going to pass
in our board object.
So once we have this, we can
return it and we have this
onPostExecute method.
This is all standard Android
development experience here,
which will check to see if
anyone's won and then update
the state of the board, and if
no one has won, then it will
go back to waiting
for the player.
So if someone does win or lose
or tie, we will handle that
case by spawning a different
asynchronous task.
And this one will send
the result of the
game off to the server.
So here we have service.scores,
because scores
is the resource we're interested
in, insert, which
basically makes a request to
add a new score to the
datastore, and then we'll
send that score
as the subject here.
We execute that, and
then we're done.
And then finally, we have this
method which will get us the
list of previously-played
games.
So we'll do this one the
application loads or if we're
interested in updating that list
of scores that was at the
bottom of the game that
I showed you.
And so to do that, again, this
is all very, very simple code,
very similar in style across all
these different API calls.
So we'll call
service.scores.list, and this
will give us back a list of
scores, which we can then jump
into a UI element within our
Android application.
So now that I've done all of
that modification, we can run
this again inside
of the emulator.
Yes, this is the device
I'd like to use.
All right.
So tic-tac-toe is loaded.
And like before, you can see
it's logging all these things
on the bottom.
All of my idle instances
appeared to have died.
Yes.
All right.
So there we go.
To make your requests, I can
hit these buttons here and
play the game against
the computer.
Again, it's still not
very smart, and so
of course, I win.
But there you have it.
Pretty straightforward.
So that covers the
Android case.
And there is also iOS, so we
will jump over into actually
first, the command line.
So if you want to generate your
client iOS libraries, we
have this nice script, the
service generator, which will
generate the API library for you
and I can run this, point
it to the output of my--
basically, the discovery
document that I showed you
before and will generate all
these files into this nice
folder on the desktop here,
which I can then drag into my
Xcode application.
I've already done that
previously with
this project here.
You can see this set of files.
And then we have a very similar
development experience
to what we just did on Android
where we basically have a
service object and then we're
making calls to our API.
So you can see here,
when we're getting
the computer move.
We have this method which
queries the tic-tac-toe API.
It queries for board, calling
getMove, and passing in an
object, which is this
board object here.
When we are interested in saving
the previous game,
again, same type of calling
convention.
We're querying for scores, we're
recalling Insert, and
we're passing in an object
which is the score.
And then when we're querying
the scores, we have
queryForScoresList, list being
the method that we're calling.
And then this will generate a
list of scores which we can
then throw into a UI element.
So let's run this now.
And again, same sort of lame UI
that I have in the Android
application, and I can click on
these squares, play against
the computer, I win, it updates
my score, and so on.
Now, to show that there's no
smoke and mirrors happening
behind the scenes, let's
jump over to the App
Engine admin console.
And what this will demonstrate
is, you can actually look at
the logs for each of the
requests that just came from
all of these different
clients.
So we can start here
at the bottom.
These are my requests
coming from Chrome.
So you can see over here on
the right side Chrome 25.
Then in the middle here, we have
requests coming from the
Google HTTP Java client.
This is our Android
client library.
And then finally, at the top
here, we have requests coming
from the Google API Objective C
client library, which is, of
course, the application running
on the iOS simulator.
So you can see it's pretty
straightforward to build an
application, an API to power
that application, and then
connect it to all three of
these types of devices.
So with that, you're probably
interested in giving it a try.
So I have another QR code for
you if you'd like to grab that
and play your own game
of tic-tac-toe
feel free to do so.
And if anyone doesn't get a
chance to grab this, I have
links to all of the demo
applications that I've just
showed you, and you can feel
free to download those and run
them yourself when you're
back at home later.
See a couple devices
still in the air.
Going once.
Going twice.
Sold.
All right.
So the last piece that we're
going to talk about today is
adding authentication.
So adding authentication, as I
said before, it's relatively
straightforward, but it's a
little bit difficult for me to
demo, so I'm going to walk
through the slides, and if
anyone's interested in trying
this, we have all the sample
code provided at the end of the
deck, which you can then
download and compile at home.
So we're going to talk
particularly about the
JavaScript case.
So we have this application
backend that I made.
We have this JavaScript client
that I demonstrated before.
We're going to see what it takes
to add OAuth 2 into that
application.
So the first thing that we
need to do is we need to
modify our API annotation.
And this is basically
a one-line change.
It's really a couple lines here
because I've abstracted
out these client IDs into
their own class.
it could be one line if
you wanted it to be.
So this is the client ID
representing our JavaScript
application.
So if you're familiar with
OAuth 2, you're probably
familiar with client IDs.
If not, they're basically a
way that you can uniquely
identify an application
running code.
So here we're registering for
a client ID inside of the
Google API's console.
If you're, again, familiar with
other Google API's, it's
exactly the same process you
would do in order to use any
of those APIs.
And this will give us basically
a string that
represents our app, which we
can paste into this code.
And this will get sent along
with requests for OAuth tokens
that come from this JavaScript
application.
So now the next thing we need
to do is, we need to modify
our backend to accept this user
object that we get from
the client libraries.
So the way we do that is we add
in this user object here
as I demonstrated before
in the code.
This will be populated
automatically with the Google
account of the user who has
sent us an OAuth token.
Or in the case where there's
no OAuth token, the user
object will be null.
And we can figure out what to
do in that case depending on
the application.
So let's assume it's not null.
If it's not null, then we're
going to set the player of the
game to be whoever it is
represented by the token.
So this will give us nice per
user scores in our datastore.
And then in the case where
there's no user present, we
throw an OAuth request exception
basically saying,
hey, you need to sign
in, otherwise, you
can't use this API.
And this will give us a nice
HTTP status code that we would
expect when the user
has to sign in.
So that's all you need
to do in the backend.
You just redeploy, automatically
works, and then
it's just updating
your client.
So in the example I showed you,
we're loading one API,
tic-tac-toe.
In this updated case,
we're also going to
load the OAuth 2 API.
And then once both of these
are called, we're going to
attempt to sign in the user.
So in the case that the user
is already signed in in the
past, this will automatically
work and you'll be thrown
right into the execution of your
primary code within the
application.
In the case where the user
hasn't signed in, this won't
do anything, and you will need
to catch that behavior later,
and I'll show you the right
way to do that.
So basically, the sign-in
method, we have the client ID
that we just created.
We have scope, so basically,
we're interested in the email
scope of the user in this
particular case, and then we
have the mode.
Mode basically determines
whether or not we want to try
to automatically sign
the user in.
If we put mode to true, we will
not get a pop-up window.
And so that basically means,
don't ask the user for
permission.
Try to sign them in.
If they've already signed
in, this will succeed.
If they haven't signed in,
nothing will happen.
So the user always has to
explicitly grant permission to
user applications.
This isn't going to do anything
sneaky behind the
scenes, but once they've granted
that access, you can
automatically sign them
in in the future.
And then we're basically getting
a token calling a
callback, again, very familiar
for JavaScript developers.
And so this method here is
basically boilerplate code
that you could copy into
your own applications.
This is going to make sure
that the tokens are being
stored in the right place and
basically, make sure that the
user has actually signed in and
you have access to their
email address.
Once that's true, you then
call your endpoints.
And then the final thing
you need to add
is a sign-in button.
And so the purpose of the
sign-in button, of course, is
for the user that has never
signed into your application
to click the button triggering
the invocation of this method
here which will then
display a pop up.
And so the pop up can only
happen if it's in response to
a user action.
So pop-up blockers are in most
modern browsers at this point.
If you tried to throw a pop-up
window without the user doing
anything, it would be blocked.
But because they've clicked this
button, the pop-up window
will actually display.
So if anyone wants to try the
authenticated version of
tic-tac-toe, one last
QR code for you.
I'll leave this up here for
a second, and then I will
demonstrate application
myself.
You could probably guess
how it will go.
All right.
Tic-tac-toe.
Let's sign in.
So we hit this button.
I'm already signed into my
Google account in other tabs,
so there's no sign-in process
that I have to
go through for that.
You can see this is my test
account from the corner.
So basically, the application
wants to
know who I am on Google.
That's code for uniquely
identify your Google account.
And because they're going to
give me a user object with an
App Engine, that also gives
access to the email address.
So these are typical permissions
that you would see
within other App Engine
applications.
So that sounds reasonable
to me.
So I'll access.
I click the button, and
boom, I'm signed in.
If we go to the bottom, I
haven't played any games
previously, so we can
start playing here.
I win.
Surprise.
And my high score
is now saved.
But if I were to reload this,
I'm automatically sign in, and
the games that I've played, only
I've played, are the ones
that show up at the bottom.
I'm sure some of you out there
have won your own games of
tic-tac-toe, and they're not
basically polluting the list
of high scores that I want
to see for myself.
So that's pretty much it.
So if anyone's curious how to
build their own APIs, we've
got links here to the Endpoints
documentation and
then we also have full sample
code for Java Backend, which
includes this JavaScript
example, and then Android and
iOS clients.
And if there's Python developers
out there, we also
have a parallel example for
building this with Python too.
So that's it.
So if anyone has any
questions, I'm
happy to take them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: You mean within
Endpoints or on
App Engine in general?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: So there is--
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the question?
DAN HOLEVOET: Yes, I'll
repeat the question.
So the question was, any chance
we could support Rails
on App Engine.
And so there is no automatic
support right now but there is
support through the JVM.
So if you're comfortable running
Rails through the JVM,
that is something that
you could do.
Endpoints itself probably isn't
going to work too well
with that just because some of
the bindings aren't there.
But you could write a generic
Rails application on APP
Engine if you wanted to.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
DAN HOLEVOET: Sure.
AUDIENCE: One is the last
session information on Go.
Can you talk a little bit
advantage of using Go?
The second question is, how
do you compare your
service with AWS?
DAN HOLEVOET: So the
two questions.
The first question is, can I
talk a little bit more about
Go, some of the advantages
of Go.
And the second one is, how would
I compare this to AWS.
So the first question--
so Go is a language, of course,
designed by Google
engineers primarily to solve a
lot of the problems that they
encountered in building
complex applications.
Within App Engine, there is some
unique advantages to Go
such as incredibly fast start
up time, so we're talking on
the order usually of
milliseconds when starting up
new instances.
But it's also a very
modern language.
People really seem to enjoy
developing in Go.
I haven't spent too much time
with it myself, so I'm maybe
not the best person to ask.
But if Google software engineers
love it and say it's
great for building complex
applications, I trust their
word on it.
And I mean, like I said before,
there isn't currently
support for Endpoints within
Go, but of course, it's
something we're looking at
because it's one of the three
languages supported
on App Engine.
So for the second question,
how does App
Engine compare to AWS?
I mean, they're very, very
different products.
There are probably other
competitors to App Engine that
would make better comparisons.
But I mean, with AWS, you're
getting your own VM.
I'd be more willing to compare
that to Compute Engine than
App Engine, which is basically a
managed environment for you.
You're not tweaking VM settings
with an App Engine.
You're deploying the code and
then the team of engineers at
Google is really the one that's
worrying about all
these configuration settings.
With that said, there are things
that you can configure
with an App Engine like how many
idle instances do I want
to have, how long should they
remain alive before they get
killed by the scheduler,
things like that.
But it's basically a very
different type of environment
than you would expect if you're
familiar with AWS.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: So are
Endpoints already
available, is the question.
So Endpoints were released
as an experimental
feature last month.
And if you're familiar with
our branding, experimental
features can change, and we've
actually moved them past
experimental into what we're
calling preview.
And so those are features that
are well on their way to being
GA at which inspires more of a
vote of confidence, I think,
in people who are interested
in using them.
So Endpoints are a
preview feature.
Anyone has access to them if
they have an App Engine
account, so for you
to try them.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: We have a number
of people who are already
using them for production
applications.
And they haven't really seen
any issues with it.
So it doesn't have the same SLAs
that we have for the GA
features, but people have been
using them without problems.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Sorry.
Could you repeat the question
one more time?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Do
we have support
for a long-held requests?
I mean, no, not really.
I think that's probably the type
of situation where you'd
be better off with maybe
Compute Engine,
something like that.
That's not saying we couldn't
support them.
I'm trying to think.
I mean, we don't have support
for it right now.
Other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Yep.
So the question was on the
tic-tac-toe game, what happens
when you're authorizing the end
user on Android or iOS.
So I can actually show
you the iOS case.
Let's see.
Is this the right one?
Yeah, so the basic idea,
I mean, it's
very similar to the--
there we go.
OK.
Maybe I can't show you.
Sorry.
Basically, on Android, there's
actually no consent screen it
all, because the way we're
handling it is slightly
different from the JavaScript
and iOS case.
In that case, we're assuming
that a developer is speaking
to his own application
automatically should know who
the user is.
And so in that case, there's
no consent screen.
You automatically get access
to a user object
on the server side.
In the iOS case, it's similar
to the JavaScript one.
So you have to sign in.
It's using a web flow, so the
user will type in their
credentials if they're not
already signed in.
And you see that same consent
screen that I showed you that
would be in line in the UI
rather than pop up, of course.
But the backend code is
entirely the same.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Sorry.
Can you repeat that one?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
So Endpoints.
The question was, does it
support native apps.
Yes.
So basically, you can write
web applications.
You can write Android
applications.
You can write IOS
Works across all
three of those.
And in the feature set that
we're targeting, initially, we
really focused on mobile, but
there's other client libraries
that are part of the Google
API infrastructure and
services and environment.
And it will actually work
well with those two.
So if you want to write like a
Windows Phone app, we have a
.net client library that
you can download.
And we haven't gone through
the whole experience quite
with the same level of detail
that we have with these three
libraries that I mentioned, but
there is support in those
other libraries at least
tentatively for
this type of thing.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Ah, ActionScript
client library.
That as a good question.
I can't remember off
the top of my head
whether we have one.
We either do have one or
there was discussion
of one at some point.
I can find out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
ActionScript?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Yeah.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DAN HOLEVOET: Ah, Unity.
So Yeah.
I mean, so I mentioned there's
a C# client library.
And of course, there's a
JavaScript client library.
But I think that you would
probably need to do a bit of
work to get it working
with Unity.
So no out-of-the-box support.
Anything else?
Going once.
Going twice.
All right.
Well, thank you all very
much for coming.